[Música]
[Aplausos]
antes que nada les voy a pedir que se
pongan de pie por favor
y que todo el mundo levante los brazos
con las palmas hacia mí para una
fotografía
una fotografía especial
muy bien ya pueden sentarse de gracias
cuando sentimos emociones se nos nota en
la cara en los gestos y en ocasiones
hasta en el color
cuando sentimos vergüenza nos
ruborizamos y rubor quiere decir
enrojecimiento del rostro debido a la
vergüenza
cuando alguien siente miedo escuchamos
se quedó blanco del susto y si está
feliz decimos que está radiante
pero podemos no desde la sabiduría
popular sino desde la ciencia relacionar
emociones y colores
por un lado la ciencia dice que nuestra
forma de pensar puede influir en las
emociones
y nuestra forma de pensar está influida
por la cultura a la que nos
desenvolvemos veamos esto en clave de
emociones de colores por ejemplo el
negro es el color del luto en los que en
occidente mientras que en algunos países
de oriente es el color blanco
blanco también es el traje de la novia
porque lo asociamos a la pureza en
occidente
jamás iríamos vestidos de rojo a un
funeral
sin embargo si podríamos encontrar este
color en un duelo en sudáfrica
por otro lado también hay conductas que
son normales para nosotros sin embargo
en otros países pueden generar
indignación ira incluso mirada a los
ojos puede ser una señal de franqueza
sin embargo en algunos países orientales
como japón mirar a personas mayores
directamente a los ojos puede ser una
falta de respeto genera indignación
también resulta que la ciencia dice que
podemos sentir las emociones antes de
poder pensarlas
y es porque hay vías nerviosas
implicadas en la emoción que no pasan
por las áreas corticales asociadas al
pensamiento
así podemos perder los nervios tener una
reacción emocional que nos desborde sin
tener tiempo para procesarla y esto es
lo que el psicólogo daniel goleman llamó
secuestro emocional
por otro lado también el psicólogo paul
ekman afirma que hay seis emociones
básicas que serían alegría tristeza
miedo ira asco y sorpresa y dice que
estas emociones se ven en nuestra cara
nuestro rostro desvela la emoción a
veces aunque no queramos durante décimas
de segundo a través de micro expresiones
faciales
pero las emociones no solamente se
observan en la cara sino también en el
resto del cuerpo
laurino men más psicólogo hizo una serie
de experimentos con 701 personas de
finlandia suecia y taiwán
y les pidió que dieran color a las
emociones
cuando sentimos una emoción hay partes
de nuestro cuerpo que sentimos que se
activan que se aceleran
y hay otras partes en esa misma emoción
que nos sentimos tan activas sentimos
que la actividad se ralentiza no es tan
fuerte no es tan intensa
así les pidió que dieran color
a las emociones al estar presente una
emoción en el cuerpo les pidió que
utilizaran colores más vivos desde el
rojo al naranja el máximo el amarillo
claro que está ahí para aquellas zonas
de mayor activación corporal de mayor
velocidad 2 en fuerza en el cuerpo y
colores más fríos para esas partes del
cuerpo donde sentían que la actividad
corporal de caída se sentía menos
intensa se ralentizaba
vemos en esta imagen el color negro
simbolizaría la ausencia destacada de
emoción y de activación corporal ni alta
ni baja
y la conclusión a la que llega este
psicólogo es que se puede crear un mapa
corporal de emociones asociando estas
sensaciones corporales a colores y al
cuerpo aquí hemos presentado cinco de
estas emociones básicas y aplicaciones
puedes conocer las sensaciones
corporales vinculadas a la emoción nos
ayuda a conocer mejor los trastornos del
estado de ánimo como la ansiedad y la
depresión e incluso facilitar un nuevo
biomarcador para identificarlas y vemos
a continuación con el nombre y apellido
estas emociones básicas y es interesante
hablar y comentar un poquito qué es la
ira por ejemplo esta lámina que ven las
zonas que se reportan como más activadas
son los puños y la mandíbula que tiene
que ver con golpear y morder presente
los sentimientos de ira emoción que está
bastante relacionada a la sensación de
injusticia y la agresividad si
observamos la imagen del asco vemos que
la zona más activada es la garganta y el
sistema digestivo
el reflejo de náusea en la felicidad
todo el cuerpo está encendido el rostro
está radiante por el contrario la
tristeza vemos que el cuerpo está
desvitalizado
las extremidades están frías azules y en
inglés cuando alguien está triste
se dice feeling blood sintiéndose azul
otro caso peculiar en el miedo vemos que
está menos activado en las extremidades
y ante el miedo hay una vasoconstricción
en el flujo sanguíneo las venas bajo la
piel que podría prevenir de la pérdida
excesiva de sangre en caso de lesión
bueno pero esto ha sido subjetivo esto
es un experimento de ciencia pero
subjetiva entonces podríamos
preguntarnos cambiamos de color con las
emociones como se nos vería a través de
una cámara termográfica
la termografía es una técnica basada en
la detección de temperatura de los
cuerpos y su mayor desarrollo vino del
campo de la investigación militar
desarrollándose la visión nocturna que
permite ver el calor que despiden los
cuerpos
hay que decir la temperatura del cuerpo
está entre 36 y 37 grados la zona más
estable térmicamente la cabeza es la
frente la más variable la nariz
pero hay aplicaciones que han llegado
incluso a la medicina
ha observado inflamaciones presentes en
la artritis reumatoide
o variaciones térmicas
debido al tratamiento farmacológico y se
están desarrollando aplicaciones pues
para el diagnóstico monitorización de
tratamientos indicadores del pronóstico
para patologías como el pie diabético
carcinomas alergia un ejemplo destacado
en el brote de sars síndrome agudo
respiratorio severo de china en 2002 que
luego se extendió al resto del mundo la
termografía demostró ser una técnica
eficaz para detectar a posibles personas
infectadas parece ciencia ficción pero
no
y en el campo de la psicología
colores emociones termografía hay
aplicación
la zona más estudiada ha sido la cara
numerosas venas y arterias irrigar los
músculos de nuestra cara
y varía el flujo sanguíneo ante la
expresión emocional y eso se puede
observar térmicamente
aplicaciones entonces a la hora de
observar las emociones
a la hora de observar la ansiedad
situaciones de estrés la carga mental y
tal vez en un futuro ayudará a diseñar
puestos de trabajo más saludables en el
contacto interpersonal cuando es
necesario saber si una persona siente
vergüenza culpa o está mintiendo
a continuación veremos algunos
resultados pero antes quiero agradecer
al doctor emilio gómez milán de la
universidad de granada psicólogos por la
ayuda prestada para esta charla y
reconocer la labor del laboratorio de
termografía psicosomática y algunos de
sus profesionales
con emociones positivas aumenta la
temperatura de nuestra cara
con una alta activación fisiológica
pero disminuye con emociones negativas
de baja activación fisiológica como la
tristeza
en situaciones de carga mental las
imágenes se leen de izquierda a derecha
y el amarillo es el máximo de la escala
de esta escala térmica con carga mental
aumenta la temperatura de la frente y de
la nariz
como se observa en esta imagen
o en el caso de la ansiedad aumenta la
temperatura en la cara y en las manos
de hecho las manos
se ven amarillas ha aumentado la
temperatura cuando esta persona ha sido
pues inducida a sentir ansiedad
en el caso del amor romántico o pasional
se observa que aumenta la temperatura de
la cara del pecho y de las manos aún sin
entrar en contacto con la persona amada
simplemente viendo una fotografía de la
persona que uno ama
algo parecido pasa en el caso del amor
divino en personas creyentes que
observan imágenes
simbolizan a dios o están relacionadas
con sus creían sus creencias también
aumenta el mapa térmico de la cara como
se observa en estas imágenes en la
imagen superior o en la inferior en la
que aumenta la temperatura en la zona
ocular
un caso curioso es de la mentira
porque cuando mentimos se ha observado
que desciende la temperatura de las
manos
y de la nariz hasta en un grado
centígrado ya esto se le llama efecto
pinocho
este es un hombre que está mintiendo
también ha disminuido la temperatura de
la frente
y se ve quizás más claro en esta imagen
la columna izquierda representa su
nombre en reposo tranquilo fotografiado
en distintos planos y la columna de la
derecha es el experimento se le ha
pedido que improvise una mentira
por teléfono en este caso a su esposa y
menos mal que los móviles no tienen
cámara termográfica incorporada de
momento porque están mintiendo se le ve
la nariz
bueno
la charla ha versado sobre emociones y
colores desde
lo que la ciencia aporta y la edición de
este año va sobre mestura así que les
propongo un último experimento y para
ello les pido que se pongan en pie
nuevamente
y que den un abrazo a la persona que
tienen al lado pero no un abrazo
cualquiera lo vamos a cronometrar y no
va a ser de esos abrazos que distan
medio metro
no no por favor un abrazo de verdad
en el que permiten permitan que aumente
sus niveles de oxitocina la hormona del
abrazo una de las hormonas de la
felicidad
así que vamos a comenzar
ya
respiren
aflojen sé
bien bien vayan separándose gracias
gracias no se siente no se sienten
porque el experimento no ha acabado
todavía vamos a pedir nuevamente que
levanten las manos para una última
fotografía termográfica está claro y
veamos si ha habido algún cambio y si no
que al menos se lleve en este abrazo que
se han dado que esto no se ve todos los
días
gracias
[Aplausos]